[Music]
what do you chlid twelve-year-old
Einstein an American President James
Garfield have in common they all came up
with elegant proofs for the famous
Pythagorean theorem the rule that says
for a right triangle
the square of one side plus the square
of the other side is equal to the square
of the hypotenuse in other words a
squared plus B squared equals C squared
this statement is one of the most
fundamental rules of geometry and the
basis for practical applications like
constructing stable buildings and
triangulating GPS coordinates the
theorem is named for Pythagoras a Greek
philosopher and mathematician in the 6th
century BC but it was known more than a
thousand years earlier a Babylonian
tablet from around 1800 BC lists fifteen
sets of numbers that satisfy the theorem
some historians speculate that ancient
Egyptian surveyors used one such set of
numbers three four five to make square
corners the theory is that surveyors
could stretch a knotted rope with 12
equal segments to form a triangle with
sides of length three four and five
according to the converse of the
Pythagorean theorem that has to make a
right triangle and therefore a square
corner and the earliest known Indian
mathematical texts written between 800
and 600 BC state that a rope stretched
across the diagonal of a square produces
a square twice as large as the original
one that relationship can be derived
from the Pythagorean theorem but how do
we know that the theorem is true for
every right triangle on a flat surface
not just the ones these mathematicians
and surveyors knew about because we can
prove it proofs use existing
mathematical rules and logic to
demonstrate that a theorem must hold
true all the time
one classic proof often attributed to
Pythagoras himself uses a strategy
called proof by rearrangement take four
identical right triangles with side
lengths a and B and hypotenuse length C
arrange them so that their hypotenuse is
form a tilted square the area of that
square is C squared now rearrange the
triangles into two rectangles leaving
smaller squares on either side the areas
of those squares are a squared and B
squared
here's the key the total area of the
figure didn't change and the areas of
the triangles didn't change so the empty
space in one C squared must be equal to
the empty space in the other a squared
plus B squared another proof comes from
a fellow Greek mathematician Euclid and
was also stumbled upon almost 2,000
years later by twelve-year-old Einstein
this proof divides one right triangle
into two others and uses the principle
that if the corresponding angles of two
triangles are the same the ratio of
their sides is the same two so for these
three similar triangles you can write
these expressions for their sides
[Music]
next rearrange the terms and finally add
the two equations together and simplify
to get a b squared plus AC squared
equals BC squared or a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
here's one that uses tessellation a
repeating geometric pattern for a more
visual proof can you see how it works
pause the video if you'd like some time
to think about it here's the answer the
dark gray square is a squared and the
light gray one is B squared the one
outlined in blue is C squared
each blue outlined square contains the
pieces of exactly one dark and one light
gray square proving the Pythagorean
theorem again and if you'd really like
to convince yourself you could build a
turntable with three square boxes of
equal depth connected to each other
around a right triangle if you fill the
largest square with water and spin the
turntable the water from the large
Square will perfectly fill the two
smaller ones the Pythagorean theorem has
more than 350 proofs and Counting
ranging from brilliant to obscure can
you add your own to the mix did you
enjoy this lesson if so please consider
supporting our nonprofit mission by
visiting patreon.com slash Ted Edie
[Music]